[energetic music]
- Desks say a lot about the people
who work at them. My
desk, says I'm booked.
Because I'm D to the S Destinee.
Unfortunately for my girl
Shauna, her desk screams
earthy hoarder but that's
all about to change.
Shauna has no idea, I'm
here to pimp her desk.
- This is my desk this is where
I get all my best work done.
My desk is like crowded with like nothing.
I kind of feel like I
have a lot of trinkets.
I don't like to admit that I need help,
however, I do need help with my desk.
- What's up Shauna? We're
here to pimp out your desk!
- Shut up. You're lying.
- I'm so serious.
- You're so lying.
- So serious.
- Where's Xzibit? Oh that's
why you have the braids.
- All right Shauna so, you
weren't lying about your
trinkets. What's, what's going on here?
So this your little mirror?
- Yeah because if I'm like
sitting there I'm like
Oh my God, there's something in my eye
my contact's really dry.
- You need Jesus. So which
computer are we using here?
What's happening?
- You know, I don't have good eye sight.
- So you don't even know--
- No.
- -is what you're telling me?
- She got a whole blender at her desk.
What do you plan on making?
- I spend every year trying
to get my body right.
- But it still taped.
[Laughter]
- But you know- yeah I'm going to bring
some fruit in tomorrow.
- You've got these drawers, what's this?
Girl, unacceptable,
unacceptable. Is this hot sauce?
- Okay, it's not hot sauce, it's sriracha.
I'm a writer and I love
music and I love books.
I have a book called "Cape
Verdean Blues" so I'm really
all about, kind of like my
culture and talking about that.
- All right cool so
Ryann you're in charge of
Shauna's main desk,
tell me what do you have
planned for her.
We're going to give Shauna
all the things she needs.
I mean her desk is a
little messy, it's a little
out there right now so
we're going to bring it all
and give her a lot of
organizational space.
We're going to have pages of Shauna's book
spread across the top of her desk.
We're going to laminate
them there because Shauna
likes to know what she's got
going on, it's something to
keep her centered, keep her focused.
So we're going to constantly
remind her of all of
the amazing work that she's doing.
Shauna talked about how
she kind of can't see,
she got bad eye sight,
so we're going to blow
all of that up and give her free monitors.
We are going to make sure
she has the Cape Verdean Flag
across all of those
monitors so she can always
remember where her home is.
- I'm feeling it, I'm feeling it.
- So other than that, Shauna
wants to learn how to DJ
so underneath the desk we're
going to have a turntable
in there so she can
practice scratching stuff.
She's going to have that and also, there's
going to be a microphone
attached to it so whenever
she's feeling the spirit,
she can get up and give us
some live poetry in the office.
- I like your thinking, I
like your thinking. All right
yes, so Rocky, tell me
what are you going to do
with the left side of her desk?
- So as it was there's a
lot of stuff on her desk
and we're kind of having a
hard time compartmentalizing
everything, so we decided
to give her a second desk.
Why not get a little
L-shape thing going on?
Secondly, we noticed that she
likes to get ready at work
so we're giving her a
vanity mirror of lights,
we're giving her three
wigs, and we're giving her a
drawer just for her makeup.
- Cool I like it, I'm
feeling it, I'm feeling it.
Well fellas let get this
together, let's send this
over to art. Let's pimp out Shauna's desk.
(energizing music)
- All right Shauna, when we got your desk
it was raggedy. You had
things everywhere, you had
hot sauce in drawers so--
- I'm nervous
- You ready to see your new desk?
- Yes, yes, yes, yes
- All right let's go.
Oh my God! This is
unreal. Oh my fucking God.
You fucking did this.
This is my fucking book.
Oh my God look at the - oh my God.
- All right Shauna, so we
hit you with three monitors
here. You've got a screen here
and two screens on the side
because you know you can't
see so other then that,
we hit you with a turntable
and even a microphone so
you can get up and do
whatever poetry you want
to do, at any time. Speaking
of poetry, we also got your
book, an early advanced copy
and we put some pieces on
here so you can always remind
yourself of who you are.
Yes we all that and then
I'm going to toss it over to
Rocky so he can show you
the beauty side but I just
wanted you to know, your
hair be a little dry,
so we got you three new wigs
to help you out, whenever
you come in and it's just a
little like matted you can
just woop, boop, boop swap it out.
- My shit don't mat.
- I sit next to you.
[laughter]
- All right Rocky, tell
me what'd you do with her
left side of the desk.
- So, we know you like to
come to work unprepared
and prepare at the desk. So
we gave you this beautiful
vanity mirror with lights.
Below it we have drawers
for your make-up, you can
go ahead and check that out.
- Yo look at these lashes!
- We got you some lashes
and we got you these
beautiful three wigs. We've
got your baby homemaker,
we've got your Nicki and of
course, we've got your Rihanna.
- You want to put it on?
- Yeah sure.
- Ah, ah ah
- Yes, yes
- As you can see, these
are battery powered lights.
- This is crazy.
- I'm glad you like it.
- All right Shauna, we've
hooked up your desk,
we've given you a vanity, a
turntable, a microphone so
you can tell the people what it is.
You officially been pimped.
- Ah
(energizing music)
(laughter)